all right guys
bang bang i've got will here with me
thanks so much how are you doing man
doing well have yourself punk how's
miami going i'm doing all right great
way to start off a saturday morning
little on chain metrics uh let's just
jump right in for uh for the week it
seems like we basically are just
trading between like thirty two thousand
and forty thousand dollars and it's like
range bound
explain a little bit kind of how you see
where we are right now
yeah so you know when you're just
looking at
just the the order books i mean there's
a lot of uh
buy orders set between you know like 32
to 30k
and there's a lot of buy orders set
between uh you know
40 to 42 in that range so just looking
at that alone
um we're going to need a lot of volume
to kind of break out in either direction
and until then we're just kind of range
bound so you know we're kind of in this
in this zone where it's almost like no
man's land where no one wants to take
you know a directional trade and neither
in either way because
people are just waiting to see you know
kind of kind of what the market
is saying um we've had relatively low
volume now heading into the weekend
weekends are always lower volume than
weekdays so
it'll be interesting to see perhaps if
we have any moves
um with low liquidity but yeah for now
i mean we're just pretty much rainbow
range bound and it's one of those things
where
you know in my in my humble opinion this
isn't where you
kind of you know take any trades you
just you just kind of sit it out maybe
trade the range
maybe you know pick up some at the
bottom of the range and then and then
take some off at the top of it
aside from that i think you're you're
just waiting for like confirmation in
either direction
and what talk a little bit about the
future's open interest that's super
interesting that uh that you kind of
called out that is pretty flat
yeah so um after we had that big you
know liquidation event whatever
it was like two three weeks ago now um
yeah the future's open interest is
pretty much just
completely flat um we've seen it come
back a little bit but
not not substantial at all and then the
futures contracts like
you can go in and see you know the
number of contracts that have been
opened
and since we had that drop i mean it's
pretty much just dead
um and for anybody that that as uh is
subscribed to the newsletter
if if you look on that that first
picture that's up there that bottom part
of the of the chart
that that's the futures uh contract so
you can see after we had that big
liquidation event i mean
no one no one wants to step in here
people are just waiting to see what the
market's telling them at this point
yeah and it also feels like uh i know
you've called out the dry powder and
stable coins and like there's just a
bunch of stable coins that are just
sitting there
uh i'm assuming waiting until people
know you know which direction to take
um but what are you seeing on the stable
coin dry powder
yeah so glasson has this metric called
stablecoin supply ratio
and all it does is it takes a ratio of
the stablecoin market cap
to bitcoin's market cap and so the way
you can kind of think of this is
when the when the metric goes down
there's more
stable coins in in relation to bitcoins
right so
seeing this metric really ticket a dive
down in the last two weeks i think since
twofold
first of all obviously bitcoin's market
cap has gone down a little bit
but also the fact that there's a lot of
stable coins
and i think that that kind of
illustrates that
you know there's money sitting on the
sidelines similar to what we were just
saying that that's kind of waiting to
see
you know a directional trend in the
market so
i've heard from a couple people that
kind of deal with institutional
investors that
um you know they're looking to get
lower bids filled you know perhaps in
you know the 20s right but
if they see that confirmation to the
upside you know if we have a solid break
into you know the upper 40s
um i you know then they're then they're
more willing to step
in um you know once they see the
momentum that that is going back to the
upside but
i think for now um people are just kind
of playing chicken and you see that and
the not only the futures uh contracts
but also the stable coins
it just seems like people are just
waiting out on the sidelines for now
yeah and you have this chart
where there's these like clusters of uh
price distribution
and kind of where a lot of volume trades
uh and i know that you've called out
previously between fifty three thousand
and fifty nine thousand dollars there's
a ton
uh and then also previously between
seven thousand eleven thousand dollars
but it feels like you're seeing a third
one form
here um kind of in this uh this range so
talk a little bit about those price
clusters and how people should think
about what that really means
yeah for sure so this metric is it's
called a utxo realized price
distribution
um and it's just this kind of fancy term
for
you're looking at this uh this profile
if you were to flip the chart
um vertically instead of horizontally
you're basically looking at
a volume profile of the on-chain of the
on-chain volume not not
exchange volume but on chain so yep
like you were saying we had this big
kind of distribution zone between
53 59k and you know that was why one of
the reasons why i was
you know pretty bullish uh when we were
in that zone because it looked like a
really strong zone of support
we had ten ten and a half percent of
supply had moved above
between 53 and 59 k but yeah once once
we lost that 53k
mark i mean it was pretty much straight
down from there
and then we had another kind of big
support at 47 dropped from there
and then now we've kind of found this um
this range and
call it you know once again 32 to
roughly 40k
is what the the on-chain transaction
volume is saying as well so
um in this zone we've had about uh 10 10
and a quarter percent of supply uh
exchange
which is yeah when you for anybody that
subscribes to the newsletter
um and i'm sure that uh we'll we'll
throw in the charts and as well for this
video
but you'll see these three very distinct
clusters so you have that one
between 53 59k um this one between 32
40k
and then you also have one from earlier
on
in the bull market where you know
perhaps some wouldn't even consider
this the bull market but uh between
between seven
and 11k like you were saying so that
that's about 19
of supply um and that's like a huge uh
supports down there i don't see it's
going that low but
if we were to lose you know just to you
know kind of stay neutral
if we were to lose the the 32k um
you know we kind of have a little bit of
support in like 26
and then you're looking at some perhaps
in around 22
and then one last big support at 20k
so i would if we were to break down out
of this range
i would be looking for for those
especially
20k i think is i'm not saying it
necessarily would get that low if we
broke that you know broke down but
uh that that's a really strong support
zone there um with the on-chain volume
and then also i know
um you know that that's a big uh
technical sport as well
where you know obviously that was the
previous all-time high so
that'll be a spot that a lot of people
are looking to buy as well
what's up guys before we continue with
this interview i want to quickly talk
about our sponsor
kraken kraken is one of the most
established and secure places to buy
cryptocurrencies on the internet
they've been at the forefront of the
bitcoin and blockchain revolution
for over 10 years their mission is to
bring crypto to the masses so whether
you're an og
or this is your first trade kraken has
all of the tools that you need to
achieve financial freedom
with more than 60 cryptocurrencies
available you can invest in
all of the most popular projects in the
industry including bitcoin
ethereum and many many more kraken also
provides in-depth articles
and guides on every single asset that
they list so you can get up to speed
quickly
and make smarter investment decisions
visit kraken.com
bang bang to get started today again
that's kraken.com
bang bang all right let's get back into
this interview i hope you're enjoying it
and then in terms of where the selling's
coming from it feels like it's just
all new coins right i know you've called
out in the uh analysis kind of the one
to three month old coins and also three
to six months so what's going on there
yeah so you know because of you know the
bitcoins open ledger we can track all
the
the different uh cohorts ages of the
coins you can see you know
when when coins move and then when the
when coins move out of a wallet they're
considered spent
so just looking at you know the
different cohorts of coins by age
um you you like you said we're seeing a
lot of uh
selling between that one to three months
and three to six months
um so perhaps you know these are
funds that may be accumulated in you
know
the 10 to 20k band last year at the end
of last year
and then also you know in that upper you
know 50 to 60k
range and those coins of course are
selling at a loss but
i think you know one one thing to take
away is that it's a lot of the selling
is coming from uh newer market
participants
rather than people that have been in
this market for a long time
and you can see that through this metric
called dormancy which basically just uh
looks at the amount of um it it's not
necessarily an
average of the of the coins of the age
of the coins is a different metric but
this is looking at something called coin
days destroyed
so if you if you have a coin in a wallet
for one day
it has one coin day and then once it
moves it has one coin day destroyed
or if it's in a wallet for 10 days and
then it moves out of the wallet it then
has 10 coin days destroyed
so this is looking at a ratio of that to
the to the on-chain volume
and so you can kind of get this this
clear signal uh we're
trending down since uh you call it you
know january um
it's it's been younger and younger coins
selling uh which i
think is an is a important trend to see
where you know
at the tops historically um it's it's
been
younger coins um selling kind of towards
it towards the
middle to beginning of the bull market
um
and then you know the older coins are
are coming in uh
i'm sorry the older coins are being sold
into strength uh you know towards
towards the end of the bull market
so i i think the fact that we're not
seeing
um a lot of a lot of the older coins
selling i think is
some signal because uh these are the
people that have been in the market the
longest so i think you know they're
they're the ones
they're kind of the smart money in the
space if you you know if we start to see
these older cohorts you know three to
five years
five seven years uh 10 years plus
if you start to see those people um
selling significantly i think that's you
know something to kind of raise an
eyebrow too yeah and then what about
realized losses
as kind of as people sell yeah so
realize losses is just you know if you
if you bought a coin at a higher price
um sell it at a lower price you realize
the loss
you know if you bought it at a higher
price and you're still holding
then it's unrealized so you know this is
this is just saying people are selling
at a loss and they have been since that
big
capitulation event and this is trending
down though which is a good thing
so it looks like you know these coins
are
the weak hands are almost done selling
off um
and you know we're getting close to a
bottom out and
you know realized losses but very
similar
soper which is similar to that instead
of looking at the raw number of the
losses
it's taking a ratio of uh the profit to
loss of the coins throughout the day
and we're getting close to broke even
breaking even on that
um there's this for anybody in the
newsletter you'll see this this
uh black line go across kind of the
middle of the screen
and and that's kind of the threshold for
breaking even which is
one a ratio of one and we're kind of
right on that
right on that line so that that's
something i'd be looking looking uh
to watch as well as as you start to see
you know whoever's gonna capitulate
still at a loss
has kind of done so and we're still in
this you know while we're ranging
um you you have you know still some of
these some of these uh
coins that you know are looking to exit
the market uh
are selling at a loss while you're
seeing the long-term holders come in and
scoop those coins up so that's kind of
like the process that we're in
where i know we've been saying this for
weeks now but it still is
uh weekends selling to strong hands it's
just you know
a question of how long is that process
going to take
obviously if there's people selling
there's somebody else buying and it
seems like those are all long-term
holders
yeah 100 so you know
i put together this chart where you're
comparing the long-term holder
uh supply holdings versus
the short-term holder supply holdings so
glass node for this uses
um 155-day threshold which comes out to
five months to determine if
an entity is a long-term holder and
you're seeing
those entities have been stacking really
heavily
while it seems like the shorter term
holders have been selling off pretty
significantly
and it's interesting because over the
last month
the selling from the short term holders
has offset the buying from the long term
holders
but over the last week we've actually
started to see
the long-term holders are now offsetting
the selling from the short-term holders
so it seems like we're flipping back
into this accumulation
where where either a you know the the
long-term holders are buying more
or uh b the the short-term holders are
are selling less
but you are starting to get that uh
transition from
you know the short-term holders
overpowering uh the buying of the long
term versus
you know now we're starting to see um
long terms over the last week
um stacking heavily than the shorter
term and that's something that
i think um i would like to see going
forward
um and and so that that's age but then
if we're going to talk about like the
size
of the cohorts um you've had this pretty
clear downtrend now for
like two and a half months uh two
actually i'm sorry like more like three
months
um where we've seen less and less whales
coming in on the blockchain
um and some of this is you know so for
glasnode uses a thousand btc threshold
for
you know calling someone a whale um
and so part of this is possibly just
these entities
um reshuffling their their uh holdings
into smaller wallets because
you've seen a while the whales over a
thousand btc has been turning down
um there's also been a pretty uh
significant move up
in a hundred to a thousand btc entities
so i think there's
there's uh definitely some some
reshuffling of holdings there
but overall um the the trend of of uh
entities over 1000 btc has been trending
down while
retail continues to trend up um it seems
like you know retail has really been
stacking harder than they almost ever
have in the history of bitcoin i mean
the this you know i have this chart and
it it shows
um the supply held by these these
smaller entities
and i mean it's pretty much just like
vertical right now so
i think that you know that it's two
things a it's it's bullish for bitcoin
adoption
because you have whale scaling out while
retail is scooping
up those coins and obviously the coins
are getting uh you know
more widely distributed so there's that
aspect of it where i think it's
bullish for adoption but i think in
terms of price you're gonna you're gonna
need to see
uh a jolt in wales to kind of do the
heavy lifting to get us that momentum
back to the upside
and you know possibly that that's
something that we'll see
if we have a definitive move to the
upside out of this range
we'll have to wait and see but i would
be if we if we have a strong move out of
this range and we start to get some
momentum back to the upside
um i'm going to be watching that that
number of whales chart closely
to see you know perhaps um some of that
money that that's
waiting to get a position now and trying
to get the best position possible
um if they get that confirmation perhaps
if they'll step in but
that's something i'm keeping an eye on
for sure got it
so really to summarize for this week
it's basically we're in this kind of
range-bound
um you know kind of trading there's not
tons and tons of volume uh when it comes
to futures open interest
there's not tons of uh real takeaways in
terms of where we're going directionally
it kind of feels like uh when we break
out it's going to be violent in either
direction
um and people are just kind of waiting
and seeing which direction that's going
to be
but if we do break out to the upside uh
you know you'll see people pile in and
then also on the downside
uh you also see people kind of pile in
it's just right here people are a little
uncertain about the the short-term
future
yeah yeah that that's my base case um
and
i think you know you just need one
person to kind of step in and make the
move
um and then people will follow in either
direction i guess but
uh you know supposedly there's a an
announcement
i saw a bitcoin conference put out
something that jack mullers is uh
making a big announcement today around
four so maybe that'll be the
announcement that pushes us up we'll see
what happens
absolutely all right what uh what what's
the one thing you're going to be looking
for
over the next week uh in terms of
metrics is there
there one thing specifically you're
looking at or you're just going to kind
of look at it in totality
yeah i think um you know this stuff is
is
you can't necessarily look at one thing
you kind of have to have
i like to look for confluence across
multiple things
where you know if you have several
indicators that are
um you know preferably uncorrelated that
are all telling you the same thing
and then you also are kind of looking at
the technical side of things where
i look mostly at the on-chain data but i
also
look at you know obviously some of the
some of the technicals and
if you have you know your fundamental
analysis on chain
and technicals all lining up um kind of
saying the same thing you know
statistically the odds of that
are way higher so i think you know i
think you need to look at multiple
things but if i were to just kind of pin
it on a few
um i think the the whales is definitely
one thing like seeing that that jolt
upwards and whales
uh also looking at the the future's open
interest you know if we start to have a
little move up
and then all of a sudden all all this
leverage piles in which
is possible um i don't think that would
be
super bullish short term um because all
of a sudden you
you have this big incentive for whales
to flush that leverage out
and and uh scoop up some cheaper coins
if they can liquidate all that all that
leverage
so that's something uh to look at and
then i'm just you know still following
this trend
with the short to long term holders
that's kind of it's interesting because
um in 2017 obviously we have a very
small sample size with
with these cycles but in 2017 there's
this kind of
clear dichotomy where the long-term
holders were
selling off into strength throughout the
whole cycle the short term holders were
you know buying the whole way up
basically buying the smart money's bags
the whole way up
but in 2013 you saw that and then when
we had the
you know we had two double pumps so we
had a big parabolic advance
drawdown like i think peak to trough was
like 80
or something like that and in a
relatively short amount of time like i
think a few months
and then we had the second parabolic
advance between those
you saw something similar to what we're
seeing now where
the uh the shorter term holders are
selling off in the middle of the cycle
and then the long-term holders are
coming in and stepping in in the cycle i
think this is something we touched on
last week but
uh that's a trend that i'm i'm
interested in seeing how that
continues to play out for uh moving
forward because
from that from that aspect um this is
definitely uh
not looking like like 2017. absolutely
where can we send people to find you on
the internet uh or subscribe to
the newsletter that you're writing yeah
so i'm on twitter at
w clementi iii
and then i do a newsletter every week
the friday one goes out with
pomp obviously and then monday i do it
on my channel
my channel is btc by wc3
dot sub stack dot com you can subscribe
there and i'm always putting stuff out
on twitter i just you know whenever i
see something interesting i'll throw it
out there so
if you want to follow me on there and
you know i answer i'm super active on
twitter so if you have any questions or
you know if you want to you say hey will
this is something really cool that i saw
and i'd love to chat with anybody about
the market so feel free to reach out
i uh i think you're doing a fantastic
job i think everyone else is really
enjoying it so keep up the great work
and we'll do it again next saturday
appreciate it paul have fun in miami man